this is the Berlin Wall built by the
communists to keep East Germans from
escaping to freedom in the West this is
the wall along the Chinese Korean border
built by the Chinese government to stop
North Korean refugees from entering
China this is the west bank wall built
by the Israelis to protect them from
Palestinian terrorists this is our wall
built by the United States government to
keep mostly Hispanic immigrants from
entering our country illegally we went
down to our southern border to get a
first-hand look at what's happening
there
if you ask agency on the field in our
higher ups the chain of command our
chief they will all tell you that that
we're very confident that whatever comes
through this border we're going to
apprehend Robert little dog crooks is
the founder of the mountain Minutemen he
has spent the last two years camped 50
yards from the border in the high desert
east of San Diego California what I'm
trying to do here is I'm trying to open
the eyes of the American people as to
the reality the issues on this
particular section of the border Enrique
morones is the founder of the border
angels a humanitarian group that
provides aid to migrants from Mexico our
mission statement was border Angels is
if I was hungry did you give me to eat
if I was thirsty that you give me to
drink and we've never asked anybody for
their document without interested and if
people have papers or not more than 7
million undocumented people currently
residing in the United States crossed
the border illegally another 5 million
people are here on expired visas when
most of the countries sleeping we are
out there guarding our borders
protecting the homeland over the past 15
years the US government has
significantly increased its investment
in border security the number of Border
Patrol agents has risen from 4,000 in
1992 to more than 16,000 today and
barrier fences have been built along the
urban sections of the border currently
these fences spanned three hundred miles
of our 2,000 miles southern border this
section of the wall was built in
nineteen ninety four as part of
Operation gatekeeper a massive effort to
secure the border between San Diego and
Tijuana
this area that we're in right now is
called smugglers gold we're only a few
miles from the Pacific Ocean this wall
right behind us is made out of the
landing strips from what was used in the
war in Vietnam so the planes can land in
the jungle here along our border in San
Diego sector we have stadium-style
lighting we have the remote video
surveillance system we also have seismic
intrusion devices the imperial beach in
the san diego area has changed
dramatically you know price values for
homes have gone up the quality of life
is a lot better and there's much less
crime along the border because of
operation gatekeeper the porter south of
san diego is more secure but few argue
that operation gatekeeper can be called
a success it's been a total failure as
far as you know being effective in
stopping people because what's happened
is more people are crossing the never
accept to not have to go around the
fence we shifted our focus border angels
from going into the canyons in the North
County of San Diego where we started
back in nineteen eighty six to coming
out to the desert and putting water out
in the extreme areas the smart smugglers
gonna take the [ __ ] to the weak spot see
illegal immigrants drug smugglers all
possess the same powers of water
electricity they take the path of least
resistance it's called Ohm's law and
what has happened is it says led to the
deaths of many many people how many are
out there we estimate its 10,000
according to the US government it's 4500
since operation gatekeeper started in
October of 1994 but whether it's 4500
10,000 or 1ds deaths should not be
taking place
this grave site is the largest grave
site of unidentified people in the
country that's not a military grave site
so we have these crosses that will put
out here this is no Alvey that'll not
forgotten and normally there's just a
brick says John Doe if it's a boy or a
man Jane Doe it's a little girl or a
woman and the first time I came here
there's only a few bricks and now you
have over 600 bricks it's very sad we go
down then we say the future of Mexico is
in Mexico it's not in the United States
but they look at me they go well yeah
you got a full belly and so forth and
it's easy for you to say but I got set
six kids back at home in addition to
redirecting migrant traffic to more
remote areas the Border Patrol's
increased presence along the San Diego
border has resulted in an escalation in
violent conflict that sound is a rock
part of a nightly bombardment all along
the southwestern border injuring Border
Patrol agents and damaging their
vehicles
you